okay ah adjust this a little bit more
because if I don't tinker with it after
the livestreams already started then how
would you even know it's me there we go
there we go okay I've seen Castlevania
season three yet no I haven't gotten to
it yet it's very high on my priority
list but life has yeah I'm probably
gonna be a little bit low energy tonight
if I'm being completely honest for
reasons I don't really want to get into
right now but I'm here and I'm live and
I hope everyone's doing alright hope
nobody's sick enough nonsense going out
I started Castlevania but haven't gotten
past the fourth episode um the thing is
season one is a little on the slow side
season one it very much gives the vibe
of being what was meant to be a
direct-to-dvd or Netflix movie that they
chopped into pieces so it's a little bit
weird season two is phenomenal I did
like season 1 though that's a mood
uh-huh
do you think jack will be in revolution
of the Daleks I'd 50/50 shot I figure
hufflepuff from Cornwall love that
outfit yep just it's just gray on
slightly lighter gray on black it's a
little monochrome today oh I am we even
though we don't have a specific topic
and I'm open to talking about most
things let's let's not do politics
please please it's just so exhausting
haven't gone far because I was tired oh
okay that's a totally valid reason to
only be four episodes in can't believe
Alucard turned out to be the timeless
child I forgot to say this but did you
know that the prince and the dressmaker
will be adapted into a musical I did
know and that makes me incredibly
nervous because that that book kind of
meant a lot to me to read and knowing
how fine the details were that that
thing got right it makes me very nervous
about whether or not those details would
survive adaptation or if they would
streamline so many of the little touches
that made that thing beautiful to me if
for the sake of you know trying to get a
musical to play better I was gonna say
something what was I gonna say I don't
know it'll maybe come back to me maybe
it won't sorry I'm late currently watch
rewatching series 8 of Doctor Who I'm
kind of divided is it weird I kind of
enjoyed forests of the night as is pop
really um first of the shite I I'm a
rewatch for us the night since it aired
I didn't hate it the way a lot of people
like really hate it I don't think it was
great but it seemed overheated to me
we'll see if I still hold that opinion
oh I know what I was gonna say I think
that for every twist forever in every
show now the reveal of any big secret
should just be this person's the
timeless child who's who shot junior the
timeless child what's really going on
with the island on loss the island is
the timeless triangle just have it be
the twist in everything I love your
views even though I usually don't agree
with them I given quite a bit of that
and I actually really love getting
comments like that the fact that I can
deliver what whatever it is is on my
mind i pleasantly enough that you don't
have to agree with me to enjoy hearing
it like that to me that's high praise
I appreciate that do you think bill
should have had a series with thirteen I
mean I would be curious to see the
dynamic
but like Bill's story was closed out and
I don't I mean I suppose technically
they can bring your back with like the
glass memory thing but I mean I'm not
sure it will come off as anything other
than being contrived but like taking the
narrative out even just in a vacuum of
the characters bouncing off each other
yeah I kind of would like to see that
now I have to go back through my stories
and check how many of the characters
could be the timeless child without
affecting it all of them everyone's the
timeless child
I'm the timeless child I still have to
figure out how to watch this last season
I've watched every one of your reviews
even though I haven't got any of the new
episodes yeah depending on what you've
got coming into your home as far as
streaming services or etc etc it it's
getting annoying trying to keep on top
of some of this stuff what if the lone
Cyberman was bad if it was how would you
think this will go ah god I don't even
know you look great also I took the
Pottermore test I am a Hufflepuff not a
Gryffindor the test I took before might
have been rigged oh wow I mean know
wherever you land Freddy it's all good I
feel sorry for the guy who had to scream
in his truck after the finale aired
somebody actually had to do that like
look I didn't like it either but okay
will you have you seen Torchwood will
you do any reviews of it I haven't seen
Miracle Day I've seen the rest of it I
did a review for children of earth so
you can I did that last year you can go
back and find that I have not done
reviews for any other pieces of
Torchwood
largely because I didn't really like
Torchwood all that much and I don't
really want to revisit it you know doing
the rewatch that I'm doing of the main
series you know if there are episodes
that I don't like but I like the show I
never really liked Torchwood all that
much aside from children of earth
aye aye Torchwood is on the very large
pile of things we're probably the only
way to get me to do it is for somebody
to commissioned me to do it and I hate
how mercenary that gets sometimes like
you want me to review it pay me but like
it's just that's just kind of where it
is
hey you're more feminine alter-ego do
you consider yourself to be an
individual or just yourself not as not
supposed to be rude either um so if I'm
understanding your or your question ash
I Vera or just me presenting more
feminine is not a separate persona it's
not an act it's not a mask it's not it's
just different aspects of myself being
emphasized in on different days and as a
result in different videos but it's not
um I mean like I have a stage persona
kind of I mean I am a performer but like
why present on camera feminine that's
not a character I'm playing that's
that's me
i guys love from giving me like I said
not the highest energy tonight I'm not
gonna go back up and catch questions I
missed I will try and grab them as best
I can
there's always the super chat if you
want to be sure that I see it again I
saw I feel really mercenary saying that
but like it's it's just true I have seen
dispatches from elsewhere great sci-fi
show with trans character I'm not even
sure I've heard of that one huh what was
worse hellbent heard the TV movie I
actually enjoyed the TV movie al Benton
was worse yeah that that one's not even
close if you could think of a doctor and
companion duo that is not canon what
would you like I think 12 and Graham
would be funny um I would put 12 with
evil and Smythe from the Big Finish
things that I think would be awesome or
12 in Donna or actually Donna and
anybody and
Oh somebody asked what I'm drinking like
I'm actually legitimately just drinking
water tonight that's yeah it's just been
my kind of day do you want the Daleks
and the Cybermen to battle again it's
not really on my bucket list
I gotta say it just started a couple of
weeks ago on AMC okay I would say I'd
have to check it out but I like I did
time any thoughts on how past you were
reactive meeting Vera um I don't know I
mean the thing to keep in mind is even
though I didn't really kind of formalize
a look and a style for Vera until it was
in my early 20s like I started putting
on feminine clothing or jewelry items on
my own at like 11 so I don't think I
would be that thrown off by it
All Things Considered do you feel like
the rules of Doctor Who presented itself
over the course of 50 years hinder
creative control do you feel there's a
certain point where the rules need to be
rewritten um yes and no the thing is the
rules for Doctor Who have always been
defined very loosely I mean just think
about how the show tackles the question
of can you change the past well depends
on the story being told they'll hand
wave some explanation you know fixed
moment in time time is in flux etc but
there isn't a consistent hard rule on
that and there's I think that's part of
the reason for the long jump longevity
the show doctor doesn't actually have as
many truly hard concrete rules as Laura
junkies will tell you a lot of it
it has either proven to be malleable or
was drawn intentionally vague in the
first place and it's Fannin that is
harsh and unbending as opposed to Canon
which is pretty fluid so I do think too
many rules can box up again I don't
think dr. who specifically suffers from
that though not really don't know what
that was have if you've seen Rocket Man
did you like it I like to very much it
was on my list of top ten movies of last
year so go check out that video I didn't
do a review of it um if I had the
breakroom up at that point I probably
would have put it up there but I didn't
so I didn't actually do a review isn't
it funny that diwan's master and Gomez
is Missy I had to watch Sims becoming
the prime minister ah that's true oh and
he was he wasn't even good at it oh
that's that's that's tough I noticed you
mentioned Ryan's dyspraxia more often in
the more recent reviews I wonder what
brought that on honestly a fair piece of
that Rebecca is I have I have friends
I'm one friend in particular who has
been going through a lot in terms of
their physical ability being very
impaired and it's it's done a lot to
[Music]
sort of make me better aware of the lack
of accommodations in real life and
representation in media for disabled
people and as a result of that I have
become a bit more noticing of it so I
think that's part of the reason I
probably mentioned it more recently than
I have in the past whereas before it was
just kind of like odd that that's the
thing he has but when it when it got
reminded after kind of not really coming
up for a while and then got part of a
very triumphant moment in the timeless
children.i that was great I thought that
was terrific and yeah I'm a little bit
more sensitive to it than
then I was probably even a year ago do
you want Missy to meet 13 I mean I would
just love Missy to come back full stop
would you rather see Toby Jones is a
dream Lord return our anthony head as
Finch oh I mean I want them both to come
back I probably put um Anthony Stuart
had a slight priority have you seen the
Sonic the Hedgehog you did you enjoy it
I have not seen it and I never will
that's not like a big statement of I
refuse but rather it's a case of my kid
saw it when she was that when she was
with her mother that weekend so I dodged
a bullet I didn't have to see it
so again put that on the pile of you
want to pay me to watch it sure but
otherwise know which is your favorite
fantastic beasts movie what do you mean
between the one that is flawed with good
parts and the one that's a complete and
utter disaster hmm I wonder interesting
question how awesome would it be if Jack
and thirteen met I mean I expect they
will i I'm expect I mean somebody
mentioned the possibility of that
happening in the upcoming special I'm
expecting it in the next series sonic is
the timeless child no you're wrong tails
is the timeless child ha ha
curveball my friends were all sad that
the timeless child didn't turn out to be
the sex cloud oh man
I'm sad it didn't turn out to be very
wise like Jim no isn't reading my emails
I know right completely disregarding all
of us the bugger
I loved let me be clear about this not a
complaint what I'm about to say but I
love how like the official description
on this live stream is topic list no
specific topic and it's still all Doctor
Who I should have expected that
how are you I'm doing I'm doing okay I'm
doing all right talking about companions
did you watch secret diary of a call
girl with Billie Piper I did not there
was a time period where I like had
wanted to but I never really got around
to it and it's one of those things
that's just sort of slipped down my
priority list and kind of isn't on the
list at all anymore I mean I here's what
I would say about that show if if
somebody who is actually a sex worker
recommended it to me at that I would
take it as a glowing recommendation to
watch it but otherwise and I've got a
few too many very complicated feelings
about depictions of sex work in media to
just sort of dive in on it I saw on word
over the weekend have you seen it or are
interested in seeing it I haven't seen
it if my kid hasn't seen it yet then I
will probably see it this weekend if
there's a review it's probably more
likely to go up in the break room unless
the thing completely blows me out of the
water I'm not necessarily expecting you
know to have a ton of deep thoughts on
it what do you think Sims master would
think of sonic he loves the Teletubbies
oh for goodness sake I keep forgetting
that there were references like that
with that one do you think the doctor
the child well hang on lost it I said I
wouldn't go back but when it Scrolls
back when I'm in the middle of reading
it that just ticks me off um do you
think the doctor the child doesn't
demystify the doctors character because
you can separate the two - child's is a
different person if that makes any sense
the my issue with that isn't that it it
demystifies the doctor I would say
honestly that it's a walk
as far as that particular issue goes
because on the one hand it gives us
answers to questions that at least I for
one never cared about getting answered
but it raises a ton more questions as
well so like as far as the idea of
demystifying I think that's a wash my
issue is just that it raises the
inherent importance of the character and
that just annoys me
what old villain classic who would you
bring back in season 13 my answer will
continue to be Omega until he actually
shows up and then I'll have to think of
something else
but until then that is still my answer
am i a bad person for genuinely liking
Clara no of course you're not
oh boy that's always when people ask me
that I never know if they're asking me
sincerely or if they think they're
actually gonna ignore me like people
will say in the comments
I like X thing that I just railed
against in a video and like uh you know
please forgive me or whatever like no
that's great that you liked it I wish I
did I wish that I liked Clara I don't I
don't judge you because you do I'm
envious if nothing else it is
interesting that in Harry Potter the
first book is more connected to
fantastic beasts and book two is
connected to the final with the vascular
sand on oh I guess so I I really I've
put very little thought into those
movies since for watching them and the
second time I did have to do that but
yeah would you rather have Jenny or
Susan come back at this point Jenny
because I think bringing back Susan the
idea of doing that there's just too much
weight to that there's too many years of
wait that okay
here's what I'm gonna say about the idea
of Susan if
show gets put on hiatus again or
canceled or whatever whatever ends up
being the last episode aired should end
with the doctor
whatever incarnation going to that point
in I guess it was Earth's history and
going to see Susan and however you want
to do that whether it's shooting her
from the back getting a look-alike
whatever you want to do that's how it
should end before a extended break or
hiatus or just end thing short of that I
don't think it's worth touching because
I don't think it anything can be worth
the build-up I saw that somebody asked
about whether Gallifrey 1 was worth the
trip
it totally was I would love to go again
next year but the but the problem is I I
can't I can't be certain enough of my
financial situation and come February
next year not that I'm expecting to be
like screwed but it's uncertain enough
that I can't commit as an artist as an
autistic version how do you feel about
the doctor having autism I'm I'm not
autistic is that the latest word going
out or out on me
no no of all the oddities going on with
me of all the weirdness for the you know
for the ranting geekiness and the gender
fluidity and the a dee dee no I'm not
autistic so sorry can't really answer
that okay look
right over there it's wonderful do you
relate to any of the current companions
or the doctor on some level because I'm
struggling major reason I'm not enjoying
it as much um not as much as I have in
the past and that's honestly being kind
of the like I talked about this in the
video I put up recently about them
whittling down the cast and the
possibility of it being just the doctor
and Yaz which i think would be a very
big help because I feel like that core
connection that the doctor has with the
primary companion is something that
we're lacking and without that I haven't
been able to connect to this doctor and
the way that I have with most of the
others the only other doctor that I've
had this much trouble connecting with is
the fifth doctor who also didn't really
have a definitive companion either so
who's more likely to come back jacker
river divides me so much well jag I mean
look river stories is done waves high
toward off-screen you're being waved at
sweetie if you want to you can yeah Liz
actually came over I got oh boy if we
can even I'm always cold so I have a
wildly the massive fur line thing that I
got her and I keep it my house because
it's the only way she stays warm other
than clinging to me like a sloth yeah oh
that's really important I do like sloths
[Laughter]
my wildling robe that you got for me
which I'm very much slow but yes because
I'm cheap but I don't put the heat up
very high so it's a big hat it's also a
big old house with ya lousy insulation
so mm-hmm
hi Liz great wildling club what is the
current temperature over here over there
yeah that's what I thought that they
were saying that the person that was
asking the question was saying there
that's why I was making faces that yeah
so it's like I think you might be
sticking your foot in your mouth a
little bit I don't I don't think I said
anything horribly embarrassing but I
would somebody asked what the
temperature actually today it was nearly
60 she still needs that it's not 6900
but it was during the days probably in
the forties it wasn't it's it's it's um
it was warmer yesterday yet and
yesterday was gorgeous here in Vermont
I'm like oh my gosh which way do I look
there's two things because cameras there
and chats down here okay okay I was mean
well the chats also scrolling by but you
can't keep up with that or at least I
can okay I'm gonna I'm kind of stretched
over a couple things so I'm gonna pop
back out but it was lovely seeing
everyone hi guys how did you and Liz
meet we actually went to grade school
together that's not when we started
dating
yeah no we we we read met at a at a
burlesque performance where I was
performing and you didn't recognize me
right off you know although another
friend of ours who also went to school
with us recognized me immediately I
[Music]
thought wow I mean I was a draw to take
this she recognized me because she
recognized my nose of all things
so would you rant if they reintroduce
Sarah Jane Smith how would they even do
that how would that work
do you think doctors in a storm cage I
think that probably would put her in
something better
that given that the security on those
things appears to suck so getting back
to the question that I had misunderstood
so if if as a viewer with autism you are
connecting to the doctor for those
tendencies coming through in the
characterisation and in the performance
that's wonderful whether intended or not
because some people get very hung up on
the idea that well it's not intended to
be you know an analog or a
representation of autism and my feeling
on that as always who cares who cares
what it was meant to be if it connects
if it connects to you on that level and
it is meaningful meaningful to you
through that that's wonderful whether
whether anybody meant to be or not did
you stopped it was staring at her odd
stomach I wasn't sure what was going on
the time bug is a timeless child because
its name has time in it while that means
the TARDIS is the timeless child because
time and relative dimension in space I'm
jealous of your cold-weather Texas stop
being cold as soon as I finished
knitting my Newt Scamander scarf well at
least you got the scarf done you'll have
him for next winter best companion that
needs to return canine oh man what
happened to that spin-off thing they did
for him did they actually get made I
don't know did you guys see the trailer
for what we do in the shadow season - I
still haven't seen the first season so
now I didn't watch the trailer and I had
something awesome I get your issue with
the timeless child but really has the
doctor always been special and after
over a thousand years their lifetime
their karma generations cycle bouncing
around well okay so two things about
that
the first is that
there's an inherent difference in what
makes them special because we're talking
about the difference of being special by
birth and being special by choice and
action so is the character special
regardless yes absolutely but now we're
in a situation where if the doctor had
never left Gallifrey and had never gone
out on all the adventures saved all the
people that they say they would still be
special even if they hadn't made those
choices and I don't like that I like the
idea that what makes the doctor special
and memorable and worth following is the
decisions and the choices that they've
made so that's a big part of why this
whole thing doesn't doesn't really sit
well with me and also I will always do
like I I've run out of ways to explain
people try and tell me you know the
doctor is thousands of years old he you
know saved all these different planets
and across all of time the universe is
infinite or it's supposed to be I'm not
trying to downplay you know the good
that the character does that's why we
watch them but for crying out loud they
shouldn't be a myth across all time of
space-time his face is too friggin big
or at least it's supposed to be I was a
big part of just the vibe of classic Who
that I wish knew who retained and didn't
go out of its way to stamp out the idea
that the universe is so big that the
doctor unless he ran into somebody who
literally had met him before
nobody ever had a clue who he was nobody
had ever heard of him most people hadn't
heard of Timelords he would show up
somewhere and be a fresh start every
time and the inherent underlying message
of that was the universe is too big for
him to get noticed and I prefer that I
will always prefer that over big massive
impacting everything Legend across all
of time his face and where we get the
word doctor from
no don't like it again you can justify
it it's justifiable narrative Lee in
universe doesn't mean I will ever like
it you can give it all the justification
you want III will still not like it do
you think it'd be a good idea to have
the doctor meet up with Ronny Luke or
Clyde in the future um huh I think
here's my thought on that if they never
get around to bringing back unit I think
it would be kind of neat if it turned
out that those three like started their
own sort of underground version of it
like Street like not Torchwood like
going in then you know taking on aliens
with guns but like street-level checking
out little weird stuff that that could
work for me or if unit ever does come
back have them working for unit that
would work too excuse me have you seen
Poe's I have not I've heard of it I have
not seen it like I said I am sorry I'm
missing a ton of questions they are
zooming by tonight which is good because
it means the chat's active but I love
that but like I I am sorry I'm I'm am
missing a lot of these I'm not missing
them because you're here oh yes yes yes
everyone came because they helped even
though I hadn't told them they all knew
somewhere deep down that you would be
here yeah so tell me when is your
birthday the 24th no it's the 21st so
that means it's a Saturday and that
means I will be bombed out of my skull
thank you very much
um I will be getting hand in the north
drunk I don't think I have yeah I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna leave it dangling
I'll let them I'll let them wonder at
that yes I think it works even without
the context of why we say that yeah
favorite Buffy season I go back and
forth on that um like the argument for
me tends to usually be between season 2
and season 3 and the argument goes like
this
I think season 2 has more standout
singular episodes but season 3 has the
better delivered season arc so I tend to
go back and forth between those with
season 6 sort of slipping in as an
occasional oh maybe that one but usually
it's between two and three you were
making a face so you were thinking what
in a way I think she's coming back
I'm coming back so I think that season -
I like the filament a villain element
filament filament the villain element in
that better with angel and then season
three I like the individual episodes
better and I like that like oh we have
this piece and this piece and this piece
and then six is just emotionally it's
really powerful six is draining but like
in a good way
yeah yeah a lot going on but really it
is draining and depressing often I'm so
for that it's not quite my favorite um
yeah um yeah I think that's that's my
basic I like I also like season four
better than most people and season five
better than most people season season
four is over hated yeah I would say it's
got elements again to for me the only
season that really falls on its face is
season seven but even that at least the
finale was good so you know and that
comes for a lot have you ever heard of
the movie suicide room I have not
so I therefore I have no opinion should
the jar is should the doctor ever have a
romantic relationship in his season and
for a season or no I'm not gonna read
the rest of the rest of that question
cuz the answer is no also no with a side
of no and a no shake this is such a
weird idea for an episode god it's
zipping back again ah there's such a
weird idea for the episode what if the
master used his laser sonic to turn
thirteen into a child version of that
regeneration thank you that would get
old about as quick as the rapidly aged
doctor got old like I okay fine you did
that can we stop now slice of note for
dessert
are you a red dwarf and of course I am
you smeghead do you think a vampire
companion would be interesting time
woods and vampires have bad blood
pun intended well that pond darn well
better be intended I see I don't know
here's what I'm gonna say no to that
specifically but less but yes to the
general concept of a nonhuman companion
like the only one we've had in modern
era doctor who has been nardole and even
that for all intents and purposes he was
human and they just make the occasional
joke based around pieces of him not
being human so functionally he was just
a person again
not to say that aliens aren't people but
you
you get what I mean they're so like do I
want a vampire no cuz we know the rules
of vampires - oh but I'm I would like a
non-human companion if only for how it
would vary up the dynamic hey girl how
old are you I'm 37 on the last day of
the month if that helps you be honest I
am at time of this live stream I am 37 I
will be 38 in 11 days so yes I'm six
months older than Liz imagine this for a
comic relief for children in need
special what of the act
oh goodness God slow down what if the
actors met their characters Jody meets
13 I mean maybe I don't know the the
thing is for things like the children in
need
specials like the so often those
concepts sound dumb on paper and it's
all down to execution so most ideas you
could tell me for like a sketch I'm
gonna like go and I don't know about
that because it's it's always down to
execution there there are very few
sketch concepts that sound good at least
to me even though the timeless Shia was
complete BS at least fans may finally
shut the hell up about the power yard I
am glad it wasn't the valley art I'm not
sure if that would have annoyed me more
probably not but like the Valley Arts up
there with the Rani in terms of things
that people keep thinking is coming back
and I'm like why well why do you want
that and I don't I don't get it the
value art story is done it's I had a Don
do Walking Dead videos haha
no I watched the first season of The
Walking Dead I was not impressed and
then I had friends who kept watching it
after that and whatever I would hear
them talk about it I would just think to
myself do you just hate yourself is that
why you keep watching this because you
don't seem to enjoy it and the show
doesn't seem to enjoy you watching it it
seems to be punishing you for watching
it we have we have rejection of both
media you lasted longer than I did
fair enough as I say I get your
reasoning for me the factors of their
birth does an impact on who they are why
they have done what they have done to
make them worth following like if you
don't get hung up on this stuff to the
degree to which I get hung up on it then
honestly that's probably healthier first
for you to be in that in that space I am
where I am on it
so I just gotta roll with it
not into your oh is it the thing I'm not
enjoying your show is pretty much a
mandate to being a fan of anything at
this point
hey can I just be a friend bus I don't
get hate viewing I don't like I don't
understand people who watch something
that they know they hate or at the very
least I don't get that long-term so like
I've had occasional movies that I've
watched that I was pretty dang certain I
was gonna hate and I usually did but
like that's what two hours of my life in
one sitting
people who like hate watch series that's
that's an hour a week for an extended
period of time to devote to hating
something I don't
that having been said without I I'm not
going to accuse any youtubers of only
hating something because it gets them
better views I will however point out
that I have the analytics of my own
channel to prove that negative videos do
better than positive ones so that's a
fact just saying but taking that out of
it I I don't get that like I I
understand where you can be so committed
or invested in something you stick with
it even as it starts to go downhill but
once it's gone from I'm not enjoying it
as much anymore - I hate this
unplug just for yourself will you ever
do action figure reviews probably not
just because like I'm not I'm not enough
like as the little bits I've got up here
aren't were gifted to me by and large
I'm not um it's just not my wheelhouse
I mean I like them but I wouldn't know
what to talk about I would just be me
taking out of a box and going yeah
that's neat thanks everybody see you
next video you know I I don't I don't
know what I talked about talking about
an action figure
people have been talking radio got the
ratings um so I've actually got a video
coming out on the Doctor Who ratings on
Friday so
yeah have you poisoned Liz with your
ring yet no but I gave her her poison
ring which Oh apparently she's wearing
so hang on I got it okay so that's
that's her poison ring [ __ ] I I had to
hunt to find a ring small enough for her
finger it's kind of crazy why is why is
it doing that to me this is weird
sorry but you're not actually 37-year
the timeless job remember everything you
know is a lie uh
God's sake yeah how would you feel about
the doctor traveling with Suzy Brooke
and traveling with the guilt of waters
of Mars Oh
if it wasn't as long as it's not a
gimmick and like they make that the core
of the story that could be interesting
would it be weird if Doctor Who never
ever again brings up the fact of the
timeless child because if that happens
would it be panic writing I mean we
don't know how much chip dawn plans to
personally milk this storyline I
wouldn't be surprised if whoever comes
in after him ignores it I figured he's
got to have some ideas for what to do
with it um riverdale season one murder
in the small city season two a murder in
the murder in a city season three some
guy caused plays a tree and tries to
convince children to commit suicide
using a board game liz watches Riverdale
that I think buy her laughter I think
she approves of the summation tree for a
while
what is this thing that you watch it is
essentially Gotham for high school I
said what else did I say it was mixed
with I can't remember just in time for
Easter picture this marshmallow peeps as
a Whovian company and you know what you
could do just bring him Frobisher and
have him shape-shift into a marshmallow
peep for a while best of both worlds
because we should have that penguin on
the show gosh darn it
have you seen Bojack horseman by the way
I haven't I've actually I've I've kind
of been deliberately not watching it um
not that I don't think it'll be good I
suspect it'll be great but I've also
heard so much about how emotionally
draining and depressing that show is and
I haven't been I haven't been in a
headspace where I want to sink into that
for the length of a season of television
much less 5 or what is it 6 now B so
like for me to dip into someone like
that again it's it's a matter of length
of time so like I can do a depressing
movie I can do an episode of black
mirrors some of those are friggin go
white Christmas broke me but it's still
only an hour and then I can walk away
and not be like well I have to see what
happens next for however long the
seasons last so I just I'm I'm sure it's
great it just makes me really nervous to
try and watch if you could play any
Doctor Who villain who would it be
oh um huh I mean my natural inclination
would be a version of the dream Lord
just for the best opportunity to mess
with and mock
the the doctor if I was gonna go that
way uh hold on there was something here
I lost it whatever I can't keep up I
keep trying
folks I really do at least the fact it
was revealed in the matrix which has
been shown to be unreliable and passed
so there's an opening to a ret Kannada
way in the future like yes there's an
opening for it but I put the video up in
the break room earlier today on why I
don't think at least as of right now we
should be accepting it as canon that
seems to be the intent will you review
every screwdriver reviewing the
screwdrivers is one of those things that
has been tossed out excuse me on the
patreon as a possible thing but they
voted for other stuff so I'm sure I'll
get to it eventually all right
do you watch anime at all the occasional
anime film I don't do a lot of or really
hardly any anime TV series I got to jump
over to the discord and hit up the chat
in there because standard plugin
reminder the discord server for council
geeks is a patreon exclusive perk and it
includes a channel where I if you ask a
question I guarantee able to answer it
the only way to get a guarantee I will
answer questions is with the super chat
or through the discord so sign up for
the patreon give me money yay so let's
see um I needed to Google Eastern
Standard Time and Greenwich Mean Time
difference Vegas five hours four hours I
was closed
oh yeah it's no longer Eastern Standard
Time it's now Eastern Daylight Time
oh god that yeah oh the pain this is for
the livestream what are your thoughts on
the rise of Skywalker novelization
making it known that Rey isn't the
daughter of Palpatine but failed clone
of Palpatine who
force-sensitive was apparently a nice
guy scale of 1 to 10 on the stupid scale
here's the thing the the fact that that
novelization revealed that that it
revealed that well not only was Rey not
the like biologically naturally
conceived granddaughter of Palpatine but
the Palpatine we saw wasn't really
Palpatine but also a clone honestly not
any stupider than what's actually in the
movie and even plugged some holes like
the fact that they didn't account for
the how the heck each survived falling
down a shaft being vaporized in a
station that then exploded so even
though that's dumb what the novelization
laid out it does plug a few of the holes
that the movie thought were just fine to
have their holes you could drive a
semi-truck through my uni lecturer
worked with the BBC apparently the magic
of Doctor Who is lost when you're
sitting in the cafeteria eating your
lunch with Cybermen I mean as long as
they don't try an upgrade you during
your break I mean your latest break room
dealt with one point I was going to
raise I don't think that chip knob will
do a reverse haha
fooled you but the way was stage leaves
wiggle room for someone to undo it if
they want on the road unless he falls
out to solidify the new Canon yeah I
mean I'm sort of taking my cue with that
video and my thoughts in general from
comic books where it's fairly typical
for any writer on any long-running
character that they may introduce some
serious retcons
twists changes to the Canon that the
next writer will then either ignore or
undo or but for as long as you've got
the writer who introduced the idea it'll
stay the case generally let's see
imagine the doctor delivering one of his
or her self-important speeches I am the
doctor I am the young oncoming storm etc
them adding at the end I am the timeless
child doesn't it make you cringe well I
mean I don't think that's that's an
earned title in the same way the rest of
them are so I
doubt she would I mean she might but the
this doctor also hasn't been as prone to
speechifying generally speaking I may be
working with John Barrowman on
Eurovision oh you lucky bugger dang okay
that's just cool have you read any
Discworld books yes I have a review up
for the monstrous regimen that's the
only one I've read so far and I enjoyed
it quite a bit and I watched the
miniseries version of hogfather
I did a review of that too so I this is
one way I have to thank the patreon
supporters because Commission two
reviews are the only way I've gotten
around to the Discworld stuff and I have
enjoyed it
so if the doctor still has if the doctor
still has the unlimited regeneration
ability ie not somehow extracted which
we don't like I didn't talk about that
specifically but in general I tend to
think that that is probably no longer
the case because otherwise the time
Woods wouldn't have had to have granted
a new regeneration cycle at the end of
Smith's run but I mean you could
probably retcon or finagle that too but
anyway he's moving on with the question
they could do an episode of the main
series that was essentially cursed the
fatal death and do multiple over
generations in the same story I've seen
people suggest that I think as jokes and
that's the thing I think that only works
as a joke
and I don't want the doctor I don't want
the show to become that much of a joke
if I can help it cue all the snarky
people who are gonna be like man the
show's already a joke yeah do you think
there was a chance of someone that is a
Doctor Who purest with such a radical
change in the Canon start to revolt that
the new who is all the time just a
reboot of the series and not really
Canon I think it would seem more likely
that some will come
correct what was done either say the
master was totally lying are some of the
story is not exactly true honestly
here's the thing and again taking my cue
from comic books
if whoever the showrunner is after
Chibnall doesn't like that thing I think
their energies would be much better
spent ignoring it and doing their own
thing then building stories around
trying to fix it because the only thing
worse than a story that engages in a
massive retcon is a story that only
exists to fix a massive retcon those
things are just continuity wank
they are very unengaging again comic
books DC especially does that a lot and
it's boring and detaching and impossible
to get invested in because they keep
resetting all the dang time if the next
showrunner doesn't like the idea ignore
it and move forward don't try and go
back and change what already happened
just just don't just don't use it it's
in there if you don't like it don't use
it
binge bunch of those last year got up to
interesting times I would say that was a
oh that was talking about the Discworld
books
I'd say Pratchett is like the fantasy
equivalent of Douglas Adams yeah I got
that vibe very much from from the
monstrous regimen so with Doctor Who
opening up the can of worms does this
allow him to not be British anymore no
the doctor must be British has to be
from the British Isles somewhere I we
can have an Irish doctor I'm down for
that
we want to go there were you a
lumberjack at one time I don't know if
that's a reference to something or not
hear me out should the doctor ever have
a romantic relationship in a season or
even longer huh
when it's Jack okay so even
it's Jay alright here's what I will say
if they wanted to something to go on
between the doctor and Jack I want it to
be playful not deeply romantic because I
don't want that story for the doctor
and we already had that story with Jack
with Ianto back on Torchwood so if it's
going to be Jack then they can have
their fun but it can't be a full-on deep
emotional romance like no they can be
friends with benefits which that's
basically every friend Jack ever had in
his whole life I'm pretty sure but all
right so pop it on back a little bit
longer
who what would be the worst thing to
come back in Doctor Who
what about how Danny or Cassandra I mean
I would say the absorb all off except
that I feel like if they brought that
back it would you have the opportunity
to do some really self-aware or
interesting stuff with that is there
gonna be another female doctor
inevitably at some point I did a video
last year arguing that the next one
probably should be a woman again
otherwise Whitacre ends up being the
Fluke that gets ignored if we go right
back to a man again
but you know the murca oh oh I'm getting
ready to start buying Doctor Who
audible care to recommend the first one
I should go for um my general
recommendation is going to be anything
written by Robert Sherman I am going to
recommend you start with you start with
ones that have your favorite doctor that
you really like from the main range
don't dive into the box sets right off
the bat largely because they are a mass
of dollar commitment they are expensive
and if you end up not liking them all
that much which I have with a couple of
the box sets it really is annoying
whereas it when when it's just the one
offs it's not as big a risk my top
recommendation would probably be either
chimes of midnight or Jubilee Jubilee is
a pretty easy one to get into because
the episode Dalek from series 1 is based
on it so you kind of have an easy hook
in so that if you're not used to audio
dramas as a medium it's it's a story
that you already know parts of so it
gets you into the swing of it better if
you're new to the medium in general
otherwise I'd say jump to chimes at
midnight both Robert Sherman and both
excellent have you listened to Big
Finish Missy set yet I have started to
I've listened to the first part of that
there was there was a question I saw
that somebody asked that I wanted to
answer and now I can't remember what was
Oh Eddie Izzard is Doctor Who no Eddie
Izzard for the master that that's my
pick thing do you think Joe marm will be
the next Doctor I kind of want her to be
I don't I don't know but I would like
that to be the case but we'll see spare
parts spare parts is good but I didn't
love it as much as a lot of people love
it have you listened to Zagreus that as
a trip I haven't gotten to that one yet
it's on my to-do list what do you what
do you think about what the Masters
reveal about regeneration being genetic
trade implies about River songs origin I
don't think it implies anything if you
are implying what I think you're
implying no the thing to remember with
that whole thing was that she was never
legitimately the same thing she was she
was an approximation
she was a mock-up version so she was
never
straight up the exact same thing in the
first place
so do you have a favorite screwdriver
I'm still partial to at least in terms
of like ones that I have I'm still
partial to two twelves
I just kind of liked it I didn't love it
as a prop though I think as a prop on
the show I rather liked Elevens I think
for that doing homework on the live a
tradition long lived yeah it seems to be
a thing some folks do so I am gonna wrap
it up
I have Amazon audible credits I think I
can get any sense oh no because I don't
think you can get Doctor Who Big Finish
through audible I if there's Doctor Who
stuff on audible I don't think it's Big
Finish I think it's something else
unless I have completely missed the boat
in which case I could have been using
audible credits to get Big Finish stuff
I don't think you can I think you do
have to buy Big Finish stuff through Big
Finish unless they're doing like a
humble bundle or stuff like that which
they do on occasion I want to see story
where the master uses hypnosis to start
a cult I can see him offering the doctor
kool-aid wasn't kool-aid it was flavor
aid said the Botanic jackass have you
seen as Eddie Izzard sketch on Darth
Vader yes live uh-huh yeah
Lizabeth was actually with me she got me
tickets to he came to Burlington we once
saw him and that was part of that set
that was good times good night Nathaniel
and remember take it sleazy oh thank you
thank you for that
so yeah we are gonna we are gonna wrap
it up folks so I hope everyone has a
good night like um I said I'm not gonna
get into the reasons but like it's been
an off day for me and this was
helpful so thank you for for watching
thank you for listening thank you for
chatting for all that stuff thank you
for just being there because
honest-to-goodness it does actually help
sometimes so I hope everybody has a good
evening has a good rest of the week see
you in two weeks
so on the 24th which is not my birthday
but on the 24th I will I will be opening
birthday stuff that I have received from
you folks so that'll be fun
and until then I hope everyone does well
and just remember that you are beautiful
you are valid you are loved you are the
council and I'm just running the
meetings